este compromiso no podría llegar en un
momento más importante cómo salir de esa
crisis
traerá profundas consecuencias para la
sociedad nos para nuestras economías y
también para la posición de nuestra
realidad común en el mundo post común
déjeme darle dos ejemplos de lo que
podría estar conduciendo nuestra nueva
gente global el primer ejemplo es el
cambio climático el cambio climático es
la crisis tras el joven y el tema de
biodiversidad es uno de los
conductores más importantes de la
pandemia y oirás del futuro hace más de
un año
europa estableció que quería convertirse
en él
primer no continente neutral de carbono
y nosotros comenzó un nuevo green deal
queremos reducir las emisiones de
carbono por menos al menos 55 por ciento
para el 2030 pero para combatir
exitosamente el cambio climático global
necesitamos que otros enfrenten estas
ambiciones también
y lo hacen desde corea del sur está
japón desde sudáfrica hasta china
y estamos muy emocionados de que el
presidente wyden se una de nuevo al
acuerdo de parís en su primer día en el
cargo ya que los eeuu son nuestro aliado
natural en cuanto a líderes global de
clima estoy seguro de que un compromiso
transatlántico compartido a un camino
sin emisiones en 2050 díaz que la
neutralidad climática se convirtiera en
una medida de éxito global y sería un
mensaje apropiado
previo al con 26 la siguiente
conferencia climática que ocurrirá en
glasgow luego este año acabamos de saber
y también nos felicita al presidente
vale por su iniciativa de reunir una
cumbre de líderes sobre el clima el día
de la tierra porque ahora es el momento
de la acción
y eso también es cierto cuando se resume
cómo se trata del mundo digital y el
impacto que tiene en nuestras
democracias y este es mi segundo ejemplo
el asalto al capitolio de eeuu fue un
punto de quiebre en cuanto a nuestra
discusión del impacto que la red social
y cía en nuestra democracia esto es lo
que ocurre cuando las palabras incitan a
la acción en un mundo donde hay
opiniones paralizante si se escuchan
todo el tiempo solamente falta un paso
de las teorías conspirativas a la muerte
de oficiales de policía
en septiembre la comisión lanzó el acta
de servicios digitales y el marcado
digital nuestro nuevo marco para el
mundo digital y por supuesto se
impusieron límites democráticos al poder
incontrolable de las tecnologías de las
grandes compañías tecnológicas esto no
va a detener la violencia política pero
es un paso importante en el punto más
básico queremos asegurarnos de que lo
que es ilegal fuera de internet también
sea legal ilegal en internet y queremos
requerimientos claros para que la
internet sumar responsabilidades por el
contenido que se distribuye se promueve
y se remueve porque no podemos dejarle
estas decisiones que pueden tener un
gran impacto en nuestras democracias a
programas computacionales sin ninguna
supervisión humana o a las mesas
directivas de silicon valley y la última
decisión sobre facebook respecto
australia
es otra prueba de ello
hoy quiero invitar a nuestros amigos
estadounidenses a unirse a nuestra
iniciativa nuestras iniciativas juntos
podemos crear una economía digital un
libro de reglas que sea válido para todo
el mundo con una serie de reglas basadas
en nuestros valores derechos humanos
pluralismo inclusión y la protección de
la privacidad necesitamos unir fuerzas y
proteger estos valores con toda nuestra
energía damas y caballeros
una china cada vez más agresiva ha
mostrado un crecimiento económico
robusto en 2020 a pesar de la pandemia y
una rusia cada vez más desafiante y
continúan infringiendo leyes
internacionales en casa allá fuera a
pesar de las protestas de sus propios
ciudadanos depende de nosotros los eeuu
y europa
fortalecer nuestra cooperación de nuevo
como ya se ha demostrado como aliados
que confían entre ellos como aliados
indispensables hombro a hombro porque si
lideramos el camino no solamente se
tratará de unir fuerzas es una señal
para el mundo muchas gracias